These transformations are
triggered by anger and fear
don't make me angry you
wouldn't like me when i'm angry
Welcome back everyone this is going
to be my marvel she-hulk trailer
video there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs here i'll explain what's going on
it's all part of marvel's disney plus day so
we'll break it all down i'm jennifer walters
i'm a normal lawyer well not that normal i love
the whole tag that they included in there for
the 1970s incredible hulk tv series both of them
dressed in 1970s gear and then filming it in a way
like cropping it with that square aspect ratio
as if it's part of the incredible hulk series
don't make me angry you wouldn't like me when
i'm angry but if you're brand new to the channel
i'll be doing videos for all these episodes when
they premiere next year we have hawkeye episodes
that are starting in a couple weeks i'll be
doing videos for that as well and i'm doing
a disney plus giveaway for memberships all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and let
me know what else you want them to do with the
hulk family within the she-hulk and the other
hulk stuff they're doing on disney plus but just
starting with the footage the big thing here is
them introducing tatiana maslany who most of you
remember from orphan black or some of the other
series she's done she's a fantastic actress
as mcu jennifer walters she-hulk everyone's
favorite green 8-foot tall lawyer obviously mark
ruffalo's bruce banner hulk is a big part of this
series a big part of her origin story we also
know about some of the other characters that
are showing up like they've talked about
daredevil having a cameo we also know that
the abomination which we just got done watching
during shangshi and the legend of the ten rings is
going to cross over as well a lot of questions
about what was going on with him during that
maybe you'll start controlling
those punches like we've practiced
the way they cut the trailer footage here it also
seems like it's from the first couple of episodes
because it's supposed to be nine episodes like
one division so the episodes will be about the
same length as one division and they pitched it
as a legal comedy the way that kevin feige was
talking about it they might have made a couple
tweaks of that in the last year or so but the
idea is because they have nine episodes and it's
a legal comedy she's gonna be acting as a lawyer
during a lot of the episodes defending other
superheroes they'll be using that idea to cameo a
lot of different mcu characters and a lot of deep
cuts so like that's how you get abomination that's
how you get the daredevil cameo because he's also
a lawyer matt murdock during the day it's just an
opportunity to cycle a whole bunch of really cool
marvel cameo scenes through the episodes but early
theory this clip here even though it's just kind
of meant to be a funny promo the way they're using
it in the trailer here i think this might actually
be an in-universe ad for her lawyer services and
she just has bruce banner help her film an ad for
her lawyer business after she's become she-hulk in
the dialogue is just a big wink at the incredible
hulk tv series and they're dressed as if they were
actors inside the 1970s incredible hulk tv series
mr mcgee don't make me angry you wouldn't like me
when i'm angry don't make me angry you wouldn't
like me when i'm angry i'm just laughing so hard
that mark ruffalo sideburns there they start the
footage with her just introducing herself like
i'm a totally normal lawyer no not quite so normal
as they show her in her full she-hulk uniform so
because she's a lawyer she's not a scientist she's
not part of the avengers yet or anything like that
the hulk is going to be the one helping her with
all this gear all this testing equipment and get
her special costume that won't rip apart every
time she changes it's kind of like another version
of the hulk's uniform from avengers end game
during the five-year time jump between avengers
infinity war and avengers endgame when he became
professor hulk hopefully we'll get a chance to
see that happen during the series there'll
be some flashbacks or something like that
but he said he spent a bunch of time in a gamma
lab figuring out how to become professor hulk
with the hulk side of his personality and while
that was happening he was developing all the
special materials as part of his avengers costume
the weather would expand with him as he grew and
speaking of gamble labs this underground looking
gamma lab like you can see the rock face behind
him here this is probably the gamma lab that he
spent all that time in between avengers infinity
war and avengers endgame if you don't remember
what's happening with the avengers in present day
right now after avengers end game because thanos
basically leveled the new avengers base in upstate
new york it does not exist anymore that's why
i say this gamma lab is probably the separate
gamma lab that he had on his own between avengers
infinity war and avengers end game that would have
been in some other location in the new york city
area but if you're not familiar with jennifer
walter's character she is bruce banner's cousin
the whole reason why she becomes she-hulk is
because she's prosecuting the mob and they try to
take out a hit on her while the trial is going on
she starts bleeding out and the emts need a blood
transfusion and the only person who's a compatible
donor is bruce banner who has the same blood type
but because his blood is irradiated with his gamma
powers that make him the hulk she gets the blood
transfusion and that gives her her gamma powers
later while she's recuperating in the hospital
the mob tries to come back and complete the
hit on her and kill her again and that forces
her transformation into she-hulk for the first
time she hooks out in the hospital and destroys
the mob members that are trying to take her out
then she starts working with the whole to try
and figure things out figure out her powers
but in this opening scene when she's practicing
yoga here this is obviously meant to be her just
trying to clear her mind and it's just a bit of
a joke on the idea that the hook tells her later
these transformations are driven by anger and fear
and the whole joke is that because she's a lawyer
is an incredibly stressful job she goes through
that entire spectrum of really extreme emotions
during her trials one of the other differences
though between she-hulk in the regular version
of the hook i'm talking about the incredible
hook like bruce banner when he's full hold
not the current professor hulk version is that
most of the time in the comics she walks around
in sort of that halfway professor hulk type of
form like you also see this clip of her here
out on the town in this really nice formal
gown as if she's going to this special event
but she's green and eight feet tall whereas the
actual professor hulk was just like a really brief
short period in the comics and obviously it's a
little bit different for the mcu like now he's
fully become professor hulk and he's still going
to be professor hulk but i think the idea with the
first couple of episodes of the she-hulk series as
she's sort of learning the ropes getting used to
being she-hulk that she'll go through the entire
spectrum of what you've seen from the hulk so far
like she'll completely lose it go full hulk and
then eventually she'll learn to balance it out and
be more like professor hulk where she has the mind
of jennifer walters but the strength of she-hulk
the last time we saw the bruce banner
version of the hulk was in the shangxi
post-credits scene this is the clip of that
yeah I don't have her number guys stay safe
welcome to the circus so as you can see even
though the avengers base was destroyed by thanos
the avengers are still very active like there
is a backup team that's slowly coming together
with some new members like wong basically tells
shangshi that he's going to be on the new avengers
team like welcome to the team side note there are
a lot of other theories about what's going on with
the 10 rings that mystery signal is that connected
to the rings that fastos creates during the
eternals movie i'll do a separate video about that
at some point because it is a really cool theory
but bringing it back around to the abomination
i think the idea in bringing the emile blonsky
abomination back is all setting up this whole
thunderbolts dark avengers long run like a sort
of reverse avengers arc across these new marvel
phase 4 movies with val sort of being like the
dark version of nick fury going around assembling
a team so to speak i'm putting together a team
we just didn't see her during the shangshi
movie but we did see wong like he had been
working with abomination for a while like they've
been working together on him getting himself
under control they fought in that tournament
wong handed him his ass but it seemed like they
were kind of old bros the way they talk to each
other in the locker room then he takes him back
to whatever that holding facility is where they're
keeping him which is like a more hardcore version
of this containment cell inside bruce banner's
gamma lab where he's helping test she-hulk
after seeing this in the shangshi movie my theory
was is this facility where they were keeping him
where wong sort of teleported him back to was
actually the raft and it was thunderbolt ross that
was keeping him here just because that's where you
would keep someone like abomination the world's
strongest most dangerous supervillains that
were too dangerous to be kept in regular prisons
even baron zemo is being kept on the wrapped and
he doesn't have any superpowers so even though we
didn't get a val cameo recruiting abomination at
the end of the shangshi movie i do expect her to
show up at the end of she-hulk or somehow appear
during his story arc during the series but the
other big reason for bringing him back is for a
hulk rematch the whole idea during that incredible
hulk movie with their first fight is that they
were both just completely out of control and at
this point in the timeline it sounds like both of
them on both sides of this equation both the bruce
banner professor hulk and the new version of the
abomination have become way more chill versions of
the characters but there's this whole idea that
there's unfinished business between the bruce
banner hulk and his abomination i think most of
the smashing that's going to be happening in the
she-hulk series will be from she-hulk herself
on the other side of the abomination coin one
of the big she-hulk comic book villains that's
going to be in the series or one of the main
antagonists will be titania she's being played by
jameela jamil you probably remember her from the
good place i don't know what her transformation is
going to look like but i'm assuming they use the
same technology and it's the same vibe is the way
they're visualizing the she-hulk transformation
but everyone just post all your reactions to the
she-hulk trailer footage in the comments below
and what's gonna happen is they dropped a trailer
for the moon night series i'll do a video for that
next there's a brand new hawkeye clip that's
super long i don't know how much of that i'm
allowed to post so i'll try to figure that out
the next day or so as i try to work through all
these marvel trailers but i will try to do videos
for everything because they announced a whole
bunch of brand new stuff including the fact that
they're actually making new episodes of x-men the
animated series that are going to premiere in a
couple years and a marvel zombies spin-off series
while you wait for everything everyone click
here for all my other trailers i'll update the
link as soon as i post those and click here for
my full eternals movie breakdown in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!